your mom lived to be a hundred and one
and you think that that your comedy
helped her in some way be helped lift
her she was a she was an anxious woman
you know and a depressed woman but but
she had this very black sense of humor
and that was the way I could communicate
with him because you don't want your mom
to be depressed and sad and anxious you
know he wanted to have a nice time but
used to reaiise to ring her up and and
the conversations always went the same
way and I'd say had a mommy's John Joey
she said hello John yes I'm fine mom how
are you and then she would with a sort
of sense of surprise she gestured keep
it down this week and I don't know why
she was surprised cuz she was just a
little bit down this week 450
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what would you do what would you help
her through this I couldn't I didn't
know I didn't wanted to be unhappy but I
had a moment of inspiration and I'm
telling you again and it was the high
point of my creativity because she was
you know she's probably out 92 and it's
not very much fun being 92 I think
because you know all the people at the
home are dying around you like flies you
know you just sort of chatting to
someone and then you go up and get your
custard and come back and he's dead
sounds like you put her in a real nice I
wanna make this clear wasn't an old
folks home it was an elderly person's
residence good save there John so so she
was I rang her up one day and she was
quite seriously good really giving me
all the reasons that she didn't want to
go on living and you know I felt the
helpless I thought okay and I had this
moment of inspiration I said mum I have
an idea
and she what is that and I said look if
you're still feeling this way next week
I'll have a friend in Fulham and I could
give him a call if you like but only if
you like and he could come down and kill
you
how would she respond to that price a
bit surprised for a few seconds and then
she howled with laughter yeah and one
time she said to me well not one time
she was always saying to me you'll miss
me when I've gone you know it used to
irritate me yeah you'll miss me when I'm
gone you speed when I've got and who
knows maybe I will one day I don't know
[Laughter]
and I don't because I was fed up with it
you know and and she said why not and I
thought whoops whoops I've gotta cross
the lies have because because mum I said
when you die I am going to a taxidermist
and having you stuff and I said and I'm
gonna keep you in a glass case by the
front door uh-huh
every time I go out I should say bye mom
that's why when bye mommy but the lovely
thing was she was delighted yeah she was
absolutely delighted she got her she
went round the elderly person's
residence and saying to people yes when
I die my son's gonna happy stuff
[Applause]